euh alors qui euh potentiellement pour
lui succéder alors pour l'instant hein
je reste sur cette idée que des
élections internes ou en tout cas une
décision interne sera prise par les
conservateurs il y a d'autres options
possibles Richie sounach donc son
adversaire pendant la campagne
d'une certaine façon le plus logique
puisqu'il est arrivé numéro 2 de la
dernière contestation et la perdue mais
enfin il était le deuxième derrière donc
on pourrait dire bon bah en plus il
avait mon il avait prouvé que ce qui
allait se passer
la réputation de bons gestionnaire
puisqu'il a géré les finances publiques
pendant toute la période du covid sous
Boris Johnson donc il a de l'expérience
donc ça pourrait être lui il y a Jérémy
Hunt qui a été nommé Chancelier de
l'Échiquier donc ministre des Finances
il y a une semaine qui a repris qui a
annulé toutes les dispositions prises
par exemple
au pied de service avec une certaine
crédibilité en tout cas en essayant de
restaurer une crédibilité de l'État
britannique donc ça pourrait être lui
après il y a d'autres d'autres noms qui
circulent dont l'un des plus
intéressants peut être celui de Boris
Johnson
Boris Johnson pourrait revenir déjà oui
alors ça risque d'être un petit peu
difficile parce que si le parti
conservatoire veut éviter de faire des
vagues il va probablement se méfier de
cette solution les partisans les amis de
Boris Johnson il lui en reste
quelques-uns au sein du Parti
conservateur disent mais c'est sa
majorité c'est lui qui l'a gagné lors
des élections devant le peuple en 2019
donc il semble il a gagné une majorité
la plus forte depuis la circonscription
qui était soi-disant à gagner pour la
droite mais sauf qu'il a perdu beaucoup
de soutien dans ces circonscriptions il
a perdu beaucoup de soutien dans son
parti il a défrayé la chronique pendant
des mois avec
démissionner ce serait quand même assez
curieux qui prennent qu'il trouve comme
solution le rappel de Boris Johnson
comme homme providentiel mais enfin lui
est en train de regarder ce qui se passe
de très très près
il votre nom il y a celui de Penny
mordante qui était aussi candidate à la
succession de Boris Johnson c'est un un
milieu très encombré il y a beaucoup de
vocations donc elle elle a par exemple
listrus a été sommé de venir s'expliquer
au Parlement cette semaine sur le limoge
de son ministre des Finances et elle a
refusé d'y aller elle a envoyé cette
ministre Penny mordonne pour s'exprimer
à sa place qui montrait ce qui lui a
permis de montrer qu'elle pourrait tenir
le Parti conservateur j'ai un autre nom
à vous soumettre carter
de l'opposition le chef du parti
travailliste donc lui il ne va pas être
désigné comme ça en un tour de
passe-passe mais en tant que chef du
Parti travailliste il a au moins 30
points d'avance dans les sondages par
rapport aux parties conservateurs
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on explique
aujourd'hui on reprend les conservateurs
ont une immense majorité en terme de
siège au parlement donc c'est eux qui
preuve théoriquement désigner leur
premier ministre sauf que dans les
sondages s'il y avait une élection
aujourd'hui les travaillistes
gagneraient largement largement avec
kirstarmer 3 points d'avance le parti
travaillé c'était autour de 50 %
d'intensions de vote alors que le Parti
conservateur est à 20 %, ça veut dire
que le Parti travailliste aurait plus de
400 députés et le Parti conservateur on
aura à peine une centaine donc ce serait
un tsunami une une
Bérézina pour le Parti conservateur et
c'est pour cette raison qu'ils ne vont
pas convoquer des élections parce que le
moyen
mais c'est le parti majoritaire qui doit
voter d'accord pour provoquer des
élections anticipées ils ne vont
probablement pas le faire
arakiri sauf si la pression est telle
qu'on dit que ce n'est plus tenable que
la situation est trop explosive et le
Parti conservateur a trop fait subir au
pays ses divisions et s'il y a une une
clameur qui monte et c'est vraiment en
train de monter
peuple du roi ou du je ne sais pas
puisque le roi Charles ont finalement
conducteur de questions donc c'est pas
impossible mais est-ce que ce parti
conservateur donc il est au pouvoir
depuis 10 ans c'est ça depuis 12 ans 12
ans 2010 est-ce qu'il est pas un peu à
bout de souffle en bout de course et il
le sait et le sait la plupart des
députés conservateurs là ils sont plus
de 300 350 il cherche du boulot en ce
moment ils envoient des CV pour savoir
où est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir se recaser
donc ils savent bien que c'est terminé
pour eux donc ils ne veulent pas
précipiter le mouvement mais en même
temps ça serait assez simple parce que
le pays est un petit peu
otage de ces psychodrames continuelles
au sein du Parti conservateur qui nous
aura donné six premiers ministres 5
premiers ministres en 6 ans pardon oui
difficile de tenir et de rester crédible
devant les les électeurs bon si vous
deviez faire un pari là quel est le
scénario le plus probable maintenant qui
pour lui succéder sousnac sunnaque ça
sera un scénario assez
assez fiable assez assez probable donc